se asoma otra crisis política en italia
después de la decisión del movimiento
cinco estrellas de no participar a un
voto crucial una moción de confianza
parlamentaria que se llevó a cabo este
jueves en el senado italiano un gesto
símbolo de una fractura dentro del
gobierno de coalición de mario draghi la
coalición a la cual pertenece el
movimiento cinco estrellas pero desde
hace días esta formación política no
ahorra las hacia el ejecutivo y este
jueves el movimiento cinco estrellas ha
decidido no votar un decreto
gubernamental bautizado decreto ayudas
que prevé un presupuesto de 26 mil
millones de euros para contrarrestar los
aumentos de la inflación en las familias
y en las empresas italianas esta
decisión podría desencadenar la caída
del gobierno italiano ya que mario
draghi ha dicho claramente que no está
dispuesto a dirigir un gobierno sin el
pleno apoyo del movimiento cinco
estrellas draghi podría dirigirse esta
misma tarde al palacio presidencial para
hacer un balance de la situación con el
presidente sergio mataré la y
probablemente presentarle su dimisión